I always know it's gonna be a good
podcast when I can't help myself from
doing the podcast before the podcast
starts and that's because the big man
david deal the croatian sensation the
absolute lizard king is here with me
Brian Westbrook today I am back from
London I went to sleep at 4 a.m. every
night so that I wouldn't get jet lag and
it worked really yeah
that's dedication because there 5 hours
ahead o Monday night I was what our
Monday night I was simultaneously
watching that dog [ __ ] Steelers
dolphin's game and the Sixers Hawks game
on reddit and I was up till 4:00 a.m. it
was genius
I'm sure you're going third and 20 blitz
zero
[Applause]
people like tweeting and they were like
I can't believe they did this and I just
kept going I can't believe you guys care
about this game why are you watching
this is the time of the year I'm gonna
be very honest with people where
Sunday's I'm still coming into work I'm
still watching all the games but if
there's a Sunday night Thursday night or
Monday night game that is bad I am I'm
taking part of my life back I'm just
being real like what am I going to learn
I and you know I watched some of it
because I'm an addict with football and
addict but I don't need right to watch
Ryan Fitzpatrick gain elite I know Mason
Rudolph sucks like I don't need to live
this is my evaluation stage no ma'am
yeah you were in London enjoy yourself
tonight I should have gone hard I just
loved much harder before the game they
show Rosen and Fitzpatrick next to each
other starting quarterback records oh
and 300 and 3 I'm like that's a great
stat it's a great way to get people
involved in this football great
storyline yeah
so yes we're gonna do a few things we're
gonna do the cup ok a couple of
questions we have a number of topics
that went on with the trade deadline
what didn't happen what did some stuff
going online and all that but you're
here and I want to know about some giant
stuff alright let's go because
I don't know what they are I don't know
if they're building for the future I
don't know if they're trying to win
right now
but they made this move for Leonard
Williams and in my head I went Leonard
Williams in his draft he was the best
most safe player and they got him at
6:00 in the New York Jets and Wow
maybe if we put him next to Dexter
Lawrence yeah and like this new line
this is what Kettleman did in Carolina
and then I text deal and I go what do
you think this Williams trade and he
goes
it sucks I watched the film yeah so I'm
gonna turn it over to you because I've
only heard people say this is a smart
move by the giant well my whole issue
with the movement of picking up Leonard
Williams is number one you've already
spent dref equity on defensive tackles
Delvin Tomlinson BJ Hill you've already
gone out and gotten Lorenzo Carter
you know O'Shane ximena's and this is
all the last two years this is all over
the last two seasons and the big thing
that they said about Leonard Williams
well maybe he's not so much a three-four
guy he's a 4-3 guy wait a second I
thought out of USC his whole strength
was that he was versatile yeah he could
be a three four or four three guy now
all of a sudden
no no he's more valleys personality
scheme specific yeah the thing that I've
seen watching film is granted his
numbers aren't the numbers that you
would expect out of a number six overall
defensive tackle yeah when you pick a
defensive tackle in the top ten they
better come in like a man and demand the
respect immediately to where you're
sliding protections to him you're
worried about a running back like Bryan
going through the B gap to get a chip
help to the guard if they move him
inside those are things that you're
worried about so when the production
comes up well he gets pressure but he
doesn't get the set so that's telling
you that he doesn't have the burst after
he beats the offensive guard to finish
the play which game haven't we already
heard this with Olivier Vernon hmm
wasn't that the thing that we heard out
of Miami he's so close he's so close
right
his numbers didn't equate to the amount
of money that you gave to Olivier Vernon
and that's why he's
in Cleveland when you make a trade right
now to take Leonard Williams you know
that number one you're putting your
giraffe equity out there that can cost
you now not only a5 but it may move to a
four since you know you have to move
them to a long-term deal and they'll get
that compensatory pick that moves up but
then also when you look at this Giants
defense that's not the main problem you
need a number one outside pass rusher
you need a middle linebacker that can
cover tight ends and running backs you
need corner help on the outside you need
an additional safety up as opposite
Julius Peppers there are so many other
things that you could have taken care of
advantage of and taken care of on the
defensive side of the ball
other than Leonard Williams yeah when
you which games did you go back and why
I've watched an entire season so what
what were the things that popped out to
you that were positive that you think
would work well and what was I really
want to know what was the glaring thing
that you watched on film and went wow he
doesn't have that well I love the fact
that he's a run stopper if you're gonna
be an inside guy you better be able to
hold up against double teams and let
your linebackers run he has that
capability to do that do you think the a
lot of defensive tackles that can do
that that you can get into third fourth
or fifth route right you pick somebody
and you pay him that money because
they're affecting the football game by
getting after the quarterback and
getting them off the spot it's great to
get pressure but you've got to finish to
pressure almost isn't done so you saw a
lot of almost almost and a lot of time
that almost wasn't enough to get the
quarterback off of the spot yeah Dexter
Lawrence was kind of the snacks filling
up guy and they still haven't found I
mean I feel like you guys have been
looking for a pass rusher since July 4th
with jpp like I feel like ever since
then you guys have been missing a pass
rusher I mean really I mean figure all
the players that they've brought in
haven't met the standards of what Giants
defense is about yeah I've always said
and it kills me to say it but in O 7 and
11 when in the Superbowl defense wins
championships when you can affect a
quarterback like Tom Brady and you have
an Arsenal players that you can come in
and out like hockey line shifts and rush
for and have back-end help
that's how you win Super Bowls you know
who three teams have that right now and
then I'll let you go Patriots Saints
Niner
yes Packers have it - Packer wouldn't
Excel but those three waves yeah the
biggest issue that I have with the trait
is that the Giants know that they're in
a position where they have to reload
maybe that's what they're trying to do
they think so yeah you would think
they're trying to reload you're trying
to rebuild at some point you're not in
the position where you give no draft
picks so you can win in the next couple
years you're trying to reload join the
draft that's what you have to do not
right now you bring up as the great
point and that's what I was saying at
the beginning are they building from the
beginning or are they trying to win
right now or do they even have a person
in charge enough to say this is where
the direction we're going to you know
that's the big question and it's it's
half and half I almost feel like this is
where the Giants and the Jets got
themselves in trouble during the
offseason because it wasn't rebuilding
we're retooling we're not rebuilding
we're still gonna have competitive
football we're still gonna go out there
and win and be competitive and win
football games
once that changes once you go from Eli
Manning to daniel Jones now when you go
to the Jets side and all this stuff with
the trade talk what is it
well it's only our second year for the
Jets it's only our first year we still
have players on the roster from the old
GM and the old coach and regime and
they're always very easy and put it on
the old people that were there always
then to put it on the game plans that
you're putting out there Adam GaSe I'm
sitting there watching you play the New
England Patriots if you're having
problems with protection with your old
line and Sam Donald go for down base
pick four down linemen pick one
linebacker so therefore everybody knows
who they're going after and make
adjustments off of that how about
throwing the screen when to run a blitz
zero at you how about throwing a quick
slant to the man that the ball out I
just realized I love the fact that
Westbrook is in a midnight green yeah
I'm deal I'm gonna blow Giants yellow it
just the do you guys remember playing
each other absolutely
you didn't also conveniently he has a
big old ring oh that right hand right
there does he flashing it into my face
just just kind of just annoying me
tap drawing me off make it a forgot that
EMR
Ernest put it on the microphone I hate
that you feel weird no it doesn't make
me feel anything at all actually I yeah
I play one when they won so let's go oh
seven cuz that was that was like the
crazier one I think yeah because of New
England they're both crazy whatever but
when they won and the Eagles had been
owning that decade yeah and then they're
the team that knocks off the Patriots
what was the Eagles like at that time
well we were kinda so that was post TL
we were actually had a decent run at
that time but we were like you know that
team actually wasn't it wasn't a great
team you guys just got a hot at the
right time we got hot and healthy at the
right HAP's a little dazed so that team
got so hot you're like wow now you start
to think that's all we have to do we
have to make sure that November December
we get hot just like the Giants did this
is a great example if we could do that
then we got an opportunity to win so in
a weird way it kind of gave you hope it
gave us absolutely absolutely because
there were different years T ough year
but in particular where we were it
wouldn't win 1213 games easily no
problem we're talking about getting into
the playoffs yeah your time about our
seeding home-field advantage those types
of things but you guys showed you guys
wanted a road and what won three games I
wrote that year right well we won eleven
on the road and you want every road game
hero game yep
what was on her called the road warriors
we still have an NFL record though seven
season with a winning 11 straight on the
road and it was all because of a lie
right was I will tell you this I
guarantee I would not have two Super
Bowl rings if he was my quarter I
guarantee you wouldn't have two Super
Bowl rings if you didn't have OC coming
off the offensive side of the ball there
were some of the adjustments that Eli
would make were absolutely incredible
pre-snap I always tell this to people
people like well talked about his IQ
talk about his intelligence figure we
had a run just like you guys did in
Philadelphia where our offensive line
had 64 65 straight start yeah dude
you're absolutely right both of your
teams were together for like five years
yeah yours with like Trey Thomas and
John Wright never there
all those guys and you with like you
sneeze Roberto para and Mateus we had
that so what you guys played each other
it was such a great rivalry because you
knew each other so during that time we
used to have competitions where we go
out there during the practice field and
we try to beat Eli with an alert a check
inaudible oh this blitz is coming and
all that time we beat him once mm-hmm
one time in practice to get the
adjustment on the pass protection a
strong safety would have like a split
foot over he'd be like alert alert will
be how the hell did you see that and he
could just pick those things up and for
him to be able to do that and for us to
be able to stop its line to have that
cohesion that's why we won so many games
on the road it's because I could look at
rich soy bird I didn't have to say a
word and we were on the same page
offensively with what we want to do a
good against that defense with crowd
noise on it continuity is is so such a
forgotten aspect figuring out which NFL
teams are gonna be great and it's so
funny cuz every year the team that signs
the most free agents we jokingly call
them the dream team and of course like
the Browns right now yeah I mean like
everybody was like oh but then we still
pick them the win the AFC North and
Baker Mayfield volley of us no of course
no you picked them as a wildcard I
remember I did not have them make of the
playoffs you did it I did not I thought
you said to you when we talked the last
time you said maybe a wild-card I also
when I talk to you outside the Niners in
and I regret changing that but I had the
the Browns falling out okay that's
making it you did this to you so let's
do a few of the the storylines that kind
of happened
Aqib Talib it's traded to the Dolphins
in the Brock Osweiler type of mold in
essence the Dolphins I'll take the
player that you don't want to pay any
more so I can get a draft pick my
question for you guys is can you imagine
what it was like for a keep Talib to get
off the plane and to walk into the Miami
facility and pretend like he was happy
to be there
well first you don't be a dick right
well first of all he's my IR so you
never he's never playing don't never
play there but he's designated to return
so you're telling me that he could just
in essence well he can't come back into
week 15 so I mean
likely he'll never play there my images
he still go there like meet up with
Brian Flores and say hi or not what's
gonna hurt but so do you think the whole
time is that Brian yeah you know the
deal I'm not coming to meetings I ain't
coming this is my first time here I mean
now my aim is a nice place now yeah so
Miami might be a place we don't only
thing that Aqib Talib has with that
staff is familiarity because figure
blind flores was in new england was
there so at least that's one thing that
when you go back to the initial trade
talks when he was in Denver there are
only two teams that he wanted to go to
is either the Patriots are the Rams so
at least he has a familiarity with the
defense but you know outright that this
move was made for the Rams to open up
salary cap for Jalen Ramsey decided to
his long-term contract question yeah
hey LA Rams you have like it feels like
80% of your salary locked up in five
guys yeah right Golf girly it will soon
be Ramsey Donald Donald and then I'm
missing probably like Andrew Whitworth
is kinda like twenty million dollars I
know you know like one of the receivers
I think okay but anyway he was
designated to return week 15 you are in
the Super Bowl window right now and if
your corners going into the playoffs
were to leave and Jalen Ramsey you have
a chance I don't know what the benefit
is you can still pay Ramsey after the
year but unless they know that he was
not going to come back if the injury was
that bad I just thought that was the
playoff he has makes broken ribs yeah
ribs I mean they say basically five
million bucks by cutting people s anus
[ __ ] the money doesn't it make sense
I can I can understand we've seen F [ __ ]
the money because you're playing for the
Super Bowl right yeah and he gives you
the opposite side of Jalen Ramsey so we
have a veteran with experience but I
know this I know that the Rams weren't
happy with the way that he was playing
this season he wasn't playing well this
year we know that they made this move -
Jalen Ramsey so that they could play
press man with Wade Phillips right and
give that split second extra for Aaron
Donnell than the pass rush to get home
on the quarterback so that's a part of
it but then also you know for the Rams
team in order for them to trade Talib
the whole point you're trading somebody
for is the fact that you don't think
that the other team's gonna get the
return on investment on him that you did
so they feel that his play is diminished
we can move on from them even if it's
this season knowing that we'll get
something in the long run so they like
that they like their young cornerback
Torrey Hill two of them yeah I think
he's been playing well they liked them
yeah they want to give him some more
opportunities again that little money
issue there that five million bucks
doesn't sound like a lot to a football
team but when you have all those
different guys that you're paying yeah I
guess that thing is just the way they
call the games in the playoffs and how
they kind of they don't call pass
interference as much having like a
veteran corner in the playoffs I don't
know if I have value that was sad to me
also sad to me as value he's playing
good Andy Dalton
like happy birthday Andy holy [ __ ] I say
this these two things can both be right
the Bengals need to look at Ryan Finley
to see if he's the quarterback of the
future because they're rebuilding and
they should have done this a long time
ago with Andy Dalton my thing that's an
issue is they have stood behind this guy
the entire time and Andy Dalton has
never said anything bad he has stood
behind Marvin Lewis if there is any
player that could call out the ownership
of being lackluster and not trying to
win a Super Bowl it is Andy Dalton who
has been there through shitty offensive
lines and no wide receivers and no plan
and he's a top five yards thrower the
NFL right now and my I guess my issue is
i carson palmer all over against right
this is the same thing that happened to
eli when giants fans kind of got very
upset you know what i mean where they
looked at eli and they're like you could
have done better by eli you could have
like moved him or traded him but now
he's just like dead weight on this bench
i just feel like they did Andy Dalton
dirty I don't know that's me
IIIi agree with you if I'm Andy Dalton
Andy Dalton I certainly agree with you
here's the thing I still think it's the
right move an angle in the interview
they don't they don't care about your
feelings that's nice we've been there
for a long time
and guess what Brian Dawkins I know that
you're gonna be a hall-of-famer we're
cutting you send you out to to endeavor
and play out there Andy Dalton listen he
probably would
starter for any team the [ __ ] is the
dolphin whiskey right now for a bunch of
teams in the NFL and absolutely he
should have had that opportunity but
teams don't think like this you telling
me that the Cincinnati Bengals who have
shown no forethought over the last 15
years are now saying in Week five
hey we're probably not gonna play Dalton
later on so let's let's try to get
something for them when when did they
show that type of forethought when did
they show that ability to say we're
gonna foresee what's going to happen in
the future
they never have this is not a surprise
to me under contract next year as well
for seventeen five four what's
interesting you know what is dead Kappas
0-0 so any dawning only on the side and
that's exactly why there was no trade
bait out there why are you gonna trade
some for Andy Dalton when you know he's
in this season they're gonna release him
and you don't have to give up any equity
and well I would I would look around the
league and I know there's a lot of young
quarterbacks but I also think there's a
lot of teams there's a few teams right
now that are looking at their
quarterback situation and go Andy don't
we'll be great for us Tennessee is
probably and then Chicago maybe John
Elway right now with this issue at the
neck of Joe Flacco and the fact that Joe
Flacco now they do have Drew lock and
that is a thing but Annie don't like I
look at Kansas City and I'm gonna let
you talk as I'm talking okay I'm sorry
no you're good mahomes goes down yep
Matt Moore comes in played phenomenally
well New Orleans
drew Brees goes down Teddy Bridgewater
come in plays phenomenal same thing down
there with Kyle Allen the backup
quarterback position if you are truly a
Super Bowl contender is valuable if that
guy goes down but I also think Andy
Dalton is better than a lot of starters
in the NFL I'm gonna shut up now I think
what the Cincinnati Bengals are doing is
from the top office down this is a
little bit of tanking on their part
because number one you know you're not
gonna get a fair evaluation of Ryan
Finley when you have one of the worst
offensive lines in the NFL and your best
receivers not on the field anyways so
that's a part of it and then to what
this allows them to do with Zach Taylor
in his first year to get a fair
valuation of Ryan family and his
football team to figure out if he's the
future of this organization if he's not
you moved to step three with knowing
that right now at OU and eight either
you can go out and try to get in the
teddy
water race and go get an NFL free agent
or you're gonna go in and go for the
Herbert or two a type of Drabek in order
to fill this need I think they like
Finley I think that they like Finley -
yeah but the thing that you knew about
him coming out of college to the pro
game is that he was prepared in regards
to the X's and O's that going through
the the progressions in the reeds but
they always said his ceiling was so much
lower than every other quarterback it is
what are you gonna see from him Ryan
fill in the next egg games are you gonna
see I will say this when Ryan Finley
came in the preseason he was wildly
accurate you made a few good plays under
pressure and he does have some mobility
yet but I think look I agree with the
Bengals you had why waste the year of
putting up a great year for an adult so
that he could be a pro ball alternate
who the [ __ ] cares you might as well as
give this kid eight games and go let's
see what we have in Finley because if he
sucks I give he's really really bad then
you move on and that was the issue with
the giant stupid Davis Webb well that's
why you look at Davis Webb so I do agree
and that's where the whole outrage came
with pension Eli if you're really
looking towards the future give Davis
Webb the opportunity my issue is this
energy an issue my issue is where you're
the Bengals your first round pick Jonah
Williams went down in the preseason and
AJ Green did - you knew that you had no
[ __ ] chance give up then lie quite
like that to me it's just like but
there's a fourth dog you thought they
were gonna have four thought now in Week
nine yes they didn't have it before
all right so they've never had magic
trick you cool if I correct you really
quick I'm not being a dick or it for
site for forethought for site for
nothing no he brought up Teddy
Bridgewater we are gonna make a bet
right now if you'd like to jump in the
bet - right when Wesley makes a bet he
makes a money he bets monies okay money
so we got into an argument recently
about how much teddy bridgewater is
going to get paid and then we're a
writer here at bleach report Mike
Freeman had a story good read
he said he could get anywhere between 20
and 30 million dollar agency he sent me
the article I responded back first of
all there's a huge [ __ ] difference
between 20 and 30 millions there is like
can we talk about the fact of that range
like is ridiculous if you're getting 20
you're getting paid around when Annie
dalton makes if you're getting paid 30
now you're getting paid around what
carson wentz me yes so i would like to
make a bet that it's closer to 20 than
it is to 30 and i think to be fair we
make 25 the line and if it's under eyes
it's over you in 23 see but in line
that's a backup quarterback you know
what and because he went five no that's
it no I think it might get pushed up I
think it should be more around 27 I
think 23 s fair and I see 27 I'm okay
with agreeing with 23 I'm a fine with
that here today is the arbiter 25 News 8
is fair at 25 yeah it's right down the
middle the 20 you okay with 25 I'm not
okay with 25 because David's hearing
he's a Super Bowl champion two times
this may backfire on me I'll give you 24
and a half
24 a half deal what do you think what do
you think is it again I think that he's
gonna get around 26 27
the reason why you keep talking I'm the
reason why I say that is number one he's
proven that he he's healthy
- he's proven that he can guide a
football team in an adverse situation
where it takes over midpoint and it
didn't even start the season with his
team and then number three the fact that
he's a veteran with experience that has
character that everybody loves in the
locker room teams are willing to pay
more for that player especially when
you're gonna be the face of the
franchise
then another player Teddy Bridgewater
coming in gives you a better chance to
win than somebody else starting from
scratch I'll tell you let me ask you
this I'm very nervous
here's a question if you put them on a
Chicago Bears right now this season yeah
how many games do they win let's say
they end up winning I don't know six
games dishes right now even though
three and five three and four three four
no get three and four three and four
yeah so let's say they end up winning
six seven games they're probably five
and three right now that's better I
probably give them two games I give them
two games race you give them that
Oakland game in London it's a quality
that's a quality start right well that's
the question cuz that was chase Daniel
so I would I would go all of the games
try Biscay play I guess I don't know the
reason that I'm scared is when you look
at the contract salaries there is nine
quarterbacks getting paid twenty seven
million or more the ninth being Matt
Stafford so the ones on the bottom are
Stafford at 27 Garoppolo at 27 five
cousins at 28 Matt Ryan at 30 the
cousins cousins did have leverage yeah
and I mean coming the perfect time right
now what's interesting is Drew Brees
at ten is getting an average salary of
25 million a year okay so you're saying
that Teddy is going to get its so you
get paid though that's the question for
sure
now Derek Carr is also getting 25 it's
actually a great line that's a great
analysis because I look I look at car
and Brees and like Alex Smith is getting
23 and a half [ __ ] Aaron Donald's up
there Khalil max up there Nick Foles got
22 so if that's that's why I feel a
little bit confident Paul's got Teddy's
better than Nick Foles not even close
but I could see a GM going we feel
comfortable giving you 20 to 5 so you're
ahead of Nick Foles I could see that if
you're Teddy right let's say it comes
down Chicago in Miami okay Chicago says
we'll give you 23 five Miami says we
give you Tommy you're obviously gonna go
with the one I mean I strapped in a
quarterback they're doing a full
probably these guys if he's a free agent
you have you're bidding against each
other
you got a payday kid I think well Teddy
you know what why would he take less
than the golden ring out where he's
gonna be the face of a franchise we'll
know the market for Teddy when the draft
order comes out and we see how many of
these kids declare for the draft and
then through the draft process how many
of them are seen as franchise
quarterbacks and how many of these teams
that need quarterbacks have picks in the
top ten because if they're if there's
three quarterbacks and there's three
teams in the top ten
it might be a low market for teddy but
if there's let's say only well I'd say
only two let's say two doesn't come out
this injury that could [ __ ] up some tea
I heard there's gonna be four
quarterback ticket in the top ten I
heard that today you've been watching
quarterback yeah I've been watching it a
little bit but the thing that I also
wanted to mention here is that we're
talking about Teddy Bridgewater and I
know that you guys have mentioned other
teams why haven't we mention the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers oh yeah so Jameis Winston
is not gonna be on the book the
Tennessee Titans or the Tennessee Titans
so when you think about Bruce Arians
wanting a mobile quarterback which he
had some had in the long history
Steelers that can push the football
downfield
I see that as a great landing spot for
Teddy Bridgewater can tell you throw the
deep ball mr. Lee he's been okay I think
that he can make he can be made to work
in a Bruce Arians off but they would
have let it go deep in dance habit
Teddy brings you more than anything is
comfort and stability smart and you guys
know what it's like to be on a team and
you don't got the guy and what it's like
to be on the team that has the guy but
also you've been on teams I've been with
guys that get it done you know like [ __ ]
Jeff Garcia Garcia came in there and got
it done and went on a six-game winning
streak and held it down and they could
have made a run
I don't know this yeah same quarterback
your home really wasn't it was my rookie
season so I started off how about this
Gary Collins was my first quarterback
who were gone by the time David Carr
played I was now still here okay so my
rookie season two no three Kerry Collins
was my starting quarterback my backup
was Jason Garrett Wow and my third
stringer was Jesse Palmer and then from
there then we went to [ __ ] was that a
quarterback we went to straight Warner
Eli Manning after they drafted him
number one overall meant from there took
off Kerry Collins
Jason Gary yeah and Jesse Palmer yes
The Bachelor The Clapper the Kerry
Collins yeah what was I mean what three
different people I was I don't know if
he was getting down back I mean I was in
a whirlwind my rookie here starting at
Rygaard I mean I'm
sitting here evaluating the quarterback
room the thing that was interesting was
is number one I knew Jason Garrett from
his time backing up Troy Aikman in the
playoffs
I knew Kerry Collins and then at this
time Jesse was just our string backup
but by the time we got to week 17 one of
the greatest stats that nobody will ever
know who did Bruce Smith sack to get the
record for the sex is it Garrett now
Jesse Palmer Cheston were down that low
to where in the offense the only
starters in the offensive funnel that
were still left were me and Tiki Barber
week 17
did you know that Jason Garrett was
gonna be a coach during your rookie
season when he was the backup well I
mean I obviously I spent time with him I
knew he was intelligent I knew he was
smart I knew the history of Ben
background about his dad but I was only
there for one year with them that's what
happened is is in Oh for when Coach
Coughlin came in we started coming in
early for the offseason to start getting
acclimated I'll never forget the first
day I walk in and I'm going to check in
and I see Jason Garrett in the weight
room doing hand cleans with the new
strength coach yeah I go stairs I have
meetings I come downstairs Jason
Garrett's in the locker okay JG what's
this what's going on so I'm out of here
no I can't do this that's the last time
I ever saw Jason Garrett in the locker
Wow
he retired immediately editor wait so
the new strength coach came in says
we're gonna do some powerlifting throws
watching Jason Garrett do Hank leans in
the locker room and into what was he
doing were they smooth well they were
not smooth whatsoever nor should any
quarterback ever be doing he really
cleans that's gotta be a wild thing that
realization where something happens
where you go this ain't it anymore and
you think that was the moment for him
yeah yeah I know what was the moment for
him because he told me this is I'm out
of here
and then down the road in uh in 2009 he
was well the culture that the Cowboys
and he was there when I was there for
the Pro Bowl I'm like this is kind of
crazy JD this is weird looking at you
for this one is it weird to see like you
had this with deuce too and like I
remember Greg Lewis became a coach what
was the college with G Lou kids
Illinois together could you imagine that
guy being a coach because he played with
me and I was like he has nothing nothing
that a coach would have he doesn't have
any of those things I know that one
thing he's laughing he doesn't like to
go to practice or meetings still has a
legendary catch my breath Favre in the
back of the endzone and he was right
that killed me when he but I never
expected it but the thing that I knew
about GG Lou he loved the game of
football and he'd be able to relate with
the younger players yeah he wouldn't
take anybody's [ __ ] you know that I
love G loom couple fights maybe he was
he was always playing jokes yeah guys
didn't like so he's up there for a
player that you didn't think would be in
no way no way he's wide receivers coach
in Kansas City in Kansas City are there
any other guys that you have that like
you can't believe they're a coach right
now like still you know was we and I
never knew we have
went to st. Rita in Chicago he's the
quarterbacks coach of Kansas City now
too
yes yes a quarter bed the backup
quarterback that you guys girls transfer
North West West one of those
northwestern quarterbacks that everyone
says is really smart and then he doesn't
actually play in the NFL yeah
did you see the dot I showed you the
data McNabb tweet so there's this story
now if Kyrie Irving Oakland nets and
Donovan Ave was like when is Durant good
admit that he shouldn't have ever left
and then Durant tweeted back at him like
relax McNabb it was lower case McNabb
just like relax I see you this is gonna
be one load down was it from the regular
account of Berner account which was
regular full frontal so your next
Thursday McNabb is being put into the
Philadelphia Hall of Philadelphia like
the City Hall of Fame okay this may be
awkward for you but we did this thing
before where I asked Westbrook what was
the defense like the week before they
would play Eli okay cuz when when Eli
first got pulled it was like is he a
Hall of Famer and all that stuff I have
a feeling he's gonna get in I don't
wanna get into the thing about Eli but
I'm curious from your perspective what
was the Giants defense like before
playing making a habit the Eagles but
also what were they game planning with
with Westbrook
so you guys had a real me so like in
Philadelphia everybody wants it to be
Philly versus the the Cowboys yeah but
for our generations village it was
Philly times because the Cowboys weren't
very good at that point and so was
always Phillies Giants ins always going
up and down the Turnpike up and down and
you guys had a nasty defense yeah you
know a bunch of guys on the Dean line
that chirped the whole time linebackers
chirp the whole time I just want to know
what the Giants were saying about
Westbrook but also make them yeah I mean
obviously the one thing contain them you
know don't let them roll outside of the
pocket and have those extra time to make
those big plays downfield
because that's the thing we could
remember him spinning out role in one
way and just getting that extra shot
downfield and I told you this you know
there were not and I'm not puffing smoke
because you're here but I said there
weren't a lot of guys that I get up but
I used to always get up and I told you
this to watch you guys but I'm watching
you run not only because of the way that
you ran the ball but the screens you
guys used all the screen here
backside stuff you were one of the
definite players in my 11-year career
that I would get up once we were done
doing offensive line stuff to go watch
you go out there when you when an
offensive lineman watches an other team
use a lot of screens do you get jealous
damn right slow down the pass rush I'm
get to run and just find DB's like
that's gotta be a we and we used to
always say when that happens don't be an
actor be a tractor how many times do you
see an offensive lineman running the
screen and he's running the hit in
nobody's looking around pulls a
no-hitter go hit somebody you're not out
there for the camera go lay somebody out
and make a play down there argument this
week actually the traits on your retreat
Tommy yeah we're arguing because there's
not a lot of guys offensive linemen wise
that throw that they late they don't
throw and cut people anymore they just
run and just run and try to push you out
of the way try to body your mom from
from my view if you just throw it just
just throw your body out up yeah get the
defenders hands down Runyon used to
throw his father Runyon was an aster I
love John right these days legendary
football genre you didn't talk to me for
a whole year my Brooke here he'd never
talked to me it just so happened my
second year we're in the hot tub
together probably week three or four I'm
the starting
damn running back and he just gets any
like hey Wes I need you to find it sign
is ball
threw it at me and then he just talked
to me but for our street literally our
street unfunniest has time change he was
running for like congresses everything
all the rules of an offensive lineman
not going out and speaking in public or
speaking of the but now he's in charge
of the penalties yeah at the NFL office
is there an offensive lineman right now
that you get excited to go watch mash
people is it quit nelson of course yeah
you know I've known Quentin since he was
17 memory bank
he's a Jersey guy but then my offensive
line coach Harry Houston who I had for
my father yeah was that Notre Dame at
Chicago right he's what the Bears now
yeah but I remember Ronnie Staley coming
in early I remember McGlinchey I
remember Zack Martin I remember Nick
Martin because I used to go there during
the spring ball to help him coach and
I'll never forget when he came in when I
met him earlier in Red Bank and now he's
a young player my man this guy's gonna
be a good ballplayer because everything
he did revolved around football he went
did jujitsu he went and did martial arts
to work on his hands he was strictly all
about the game and he plays the way that
should from start to the end through the
whistle that's how you play ole life he
doesn't stop now ever know he kind of he
gives me a little bit of your vibes like
I remember being I told you I used to
tell you the minute that the whistles
yours I give him an extra section a
little bit extra because number one it
starts wearing them down and they start
sitting to realizing that you're on them
for the entire play for the game but two
it starts to piss them off and now the
sudden they're more worried about
fighting you than worried about doing
their job I want to try an experiment
I'm gonna say above the line bizarreness
Martin two smartest players I know on
the doggone team he's looking at you I
experiment I just bring out of here I'm
gonna say I want to see how it impacts
each of your emotions okay
oh I don't think you're on the team at
this time when were you drafted Oh 303
214 I was gonna say the play when McNabb
rolled out and hit James thrashed in the
back of the end zone on Monday Night
Football
I was before me I mean if you want to
talk about the Sean Jackson return in
the comp return
to me we've talked about that before
okay david akers in a wild card game and
it's a free ride and going in and this
is before both of you never mind we
talked about one of the worst moments
for Eagles Giants that this is before
both of your time was in the 2000-2001
divisional game when we were the
surprise team and the Giants were the
really good team and we thought mobile
Donovan had a chance and it ended with
the crazy Jason Sehorn interception
while he was neither of you guys were
there no but that one for me was like so
really was just an experimental my
emotions
trade deadline kind of sucked I am
fascinated by what's happening with the
Jets
Jamal Adams middle of this accuses the
GM of saying I'm never gonna trade you
and then reports come to him because
social media is bubbling O'Shea and
they're looking to move them
he then apparently says I'd love to go
play in Dallas on from Texas then
afterwards says I never said that and
then today in front of reporters says no
I would like to go to Dallas
Robbie Anderson is thrilled he doesn't
get traded Levien's putting out videos I
thought of all the teams they were the
one where I can't imagine being told
we're gonna trade you and then having to
go and play for that team the next day
and you're one in seven like get the
[ __ ] out of here I have no interest
think about Mohamed Sanu he went from
one in seven to eight no well that's the
great but for this I can't imagine the
Jets right now feel too great coming
back in the locker room on to what time
are you I think that it's hard because
if you're a GM just because of team
calls and says hey we're interesting to
Jamal Adams you can shut it down right
away yeah they didn't do that the judge
should have done that yet they felt that
way they should have shut it down hey
he's not on the trade block we're not
interested and they should have made a
statement about that that was it yeah
and they'd never did that which I think
that's just wrong yeah and now you have
to go back into that locker room and
look that GM in the eye like oh what's
the deal you told me that you were
building the team around me you're
getting rid of the guys in the front
line but you're also saying that I'm
gonna trade block this is the same GM
that fought Quinton Williams over
stipulations in his rookie card
tooth and nail and he didn't come back
is the same GM that had a huge issue
with Colet Co assembly yeah he recently
cut and he refused to allow to get
surgery when now two to three doctors
have already said that it was torn way
worse than it actually was it's not my
shoulder it's your shoulder it's torn
but you can play I'm okay you don't and
as you said before this is a GM that's
come in and said I want my guys yeah
well guess what probably 80% of that
locker rooms not his guys what the [ __ ]
are you feeling if you're a Jets player
right now think about it Leonard
Williams that's one thing that you can
say okay number six overall we get our
trade value back on it with the third
and fifth maybe a fourth round of
depending on how it works out we can
make this one happen
Jamal Adams regardless of what team you
put him on his arrows still going up yes
you're not sitting here thinking well if
we put him in this environment he's not
gonna produce he's gonna produce on 31
other teams that you put him on so you
know that you need a return on
investment on them then to say well you
know we weren't thinking about trading
them but these calls go back to tweets
weeks ago saying that he was unhappy you
know my job is to answer the phone
because that's what I've been told as a
GM that you should do but the minute
that they give you an ass about your
mall Adams it should be dead if they're
not it's not an option you don't want to
sell your house somebody says hey I want
to buy your house we want to offer you
this you're gonna say no I'm not selling
it but if now all of a sudden somebody
says I'm gonna offer you double what
your house is worth
now the sudden he's tradable you're
willing to sell that's where there's the
blurred lines of this it's because you
know if they would have gotten the first
in a second he would have been a Dallas
you would have traded him and would have
traded him off well if you're a gym that
is a hard spot to be in if you publicly
say I'm not trading him and then you do
you've lied to the media right and the
player more importantly also the tweet
came out I forget who it was but it was
one of the reporters it might have been
Manish saying the only two people that
were off the table were Sam dartle and
Quinn and Williams yeah so right there I
know that Jamal Adams is it's nice
available yes yes yeah but also realize
there's 50 other 51 other guys that were
not mentioned - yeah
so now they all just realized [ __ ]
Marcus may just went wait I was on the
table yeah you know what I mean like
could you imagine if you were on the
Jets and you just as of yesterday traded
Jamal Adams you'd be walking into the
locker room like the [ __ ] is going on
well here's the deal six everyone in the
locker room should be saying I'm
tradable yeah that's what they should be
saying no matter what the GM says so
that's the beginning thing the GM could
have he could have quiet it at the
beginning by saying we're not gonna
trade him the other part is this if
you're the GM of the Jets I think I
would be saying listen you know I'll
listen to your offer no think about it I
mean I don't want to trade the kid but
if you're gonna offer me something crazy
like the Dolphins got for Laremy Tunsil
then yeah if you're saying don't want to
- okay we probably still reload in a
little bit I'll take that I mean you you
have to kind of leave that door open and
now that I rethink it III look at it -
and I see look there was a lot of trade
movement earlier right we had to leave
we had Ramsey we'd Emmanuel Sanders via
Mohamed Sanu
we had a number of trades in the last I
love how nobody's talking about Michael
Bennett Michael bet on the Dallas
Cowboys on that that's a big really
upset me as an Eagles if he can get
along in a locker room for the next
eight weeks which he would she will
which he will especially because it's
Miran le
right so it's like army guy that's like
let's go kill people yeah yeah I don't
know but it's more of a free thinker
wants least disrupt everything yeah
that's what better that's what he does
so I will say this that the realization
for these GM's of the compensatory picks
that you get by allowing a guy to leave
I think has impacted the trade value
market no questions of fact that the jet
the Jets are looking at Robbie Anderson
and going you know what if he gets a
pretty good deal we might get a fourth
or fifth round pick out yeah and that
Washington's going okay if Trent
Williams signed somewhere next year
maybe we'll get something out of this
well Trent Brown that's what the New
England Patriots had when he signed with
the Raiders Patriot got of the Eagles
yeah these are the teams that have
mastered the compensatory pick market
but I also look at the Jets Washington
Cincinnati I don't think Robbie
Anderson's gonna get that big of a
contract either do i this whole Trent
Williams thing it's a depreciating asset
and he's come out there
like oh my helmet doesn't fit he's not
reporting at all no true womb and II
don't like I look at these GM's though
that have these depreciating assets that
they're not gonna be able to get maybe
they maybe they get a compensatory pick
but I just think that they're holding
onto these pieces that's why I was
laughing when people said this argument
they were trying to defend Bruce Allen
well maybe if he comes in now and he
doesn't play all season you'll get more
trade equity now you're making a 31 year
old offensive tackle who hasn't been
healthy for the last three seasons sit
out an entire year and you think you're
gonna get more draft capital for them
after you've done nothing to get
anything out of not only great not only
that look what your position your team
is it yeah your team is in a terrible
position why wouldn't you go get draft
picks
no are you telling me that if they gave
Laremy Tunsil the Dolphins gave up and
you're got a two first in a second for
Trent Williams seven-time Pro Bowler
yeah come on that's crazy
and there I was gave them up just like
that I I'm gonna do this I think for
next week of the teams that are they're
not rebuilding for the future and
they're also not super bowl eligible
it's this middle group that I feel the
worst for their fan bases because there
is no plan and there is no talent and
Washington to me is the poster child of
this a team that doesn't plan for the
future or the shirt tour short-term they
draft a quarterback but have no plan to
build around him they haven't hey a
saint thee may pay a safety eighty
million dollars and they're leaving him
out there on an island I look at
Washington and they are clearly a
franchise that is an operation to bring
an income they are not trying to win
they are not trying to grow their fan
base they are trying to make money on
ticket sales so that their owner can
have a yacht you know it's an incredible
yacht [ __ ] up I think you're right in
the premise but I think that they're
actually are trying to win this is the
weird part they're really not good at it
I think that's the part that's true
they're not good at it but I think
they're trying to win I really think
because you can't tell me that you bring
in the same thing best I wanted to be
ignorant than malicious but in this I'd
rather a-team tanks than just be so how
is juice Allen's still employed in the
NFL right from what from what the
reports have come out
he's in cahoots he's he's Snyder's buddy
there's no doubt about that absolutely
shitty owners really care about having
someone that they can control but the
question is can we made your companies
this is interesting I think you guys
would agree how many business people
have you met that have actually
surrounded themselves with kind of
idiots so that their job is secure have
you met people like that yes I have seen
it in a lot of places feel a lot smarter
does guys are loyal and they're never
gonna stab the power and I've seen that
a lot of times than like people's jobs
and they complain to me about their
businesses that's what Daniel Snyder
feels to me he surrounded himself and he
goes well at least I'm smarter than
Bruce Allen yeah if I ever need to get
rid of somebody if it ever turns to bad
that's a comfort blab salutely broke -
yeah unless you're just making a bunch
of money from the TV money but that's a
bad business think bad business sitting
on like a three-four but he's making
money he wants to win though he can't
you can't make money for him to be more
relevant he can't be Ari's rich rich he
wants to win football games which that's
the problem that he has which franchise
right now is more worse off
the Bengals or Washington Miami is
tanking there's a plan so I'm putting
them aside but Washington or Cincinnati
Washington Washington yeah consistent at
it seems to have a plan they're trying
to move to the future they're at least
looking to the future with Finley
they're saying okay they have Jonah
Williams who'll come back from each
other's back yeah but there's complete
unrest it's a it feels like a mutiny you
got a young coach yeah what Washington
is done oh if you're true Wiggins would
you have gone in though would you have
gone in Oh in week one well he hates too
because he needed to get vested this
year this point you have to go in but
he's playing it perfectly I want to
applaud Trent Williams I think Williams
is about to instead of holding out
holding well he should
this helmet doesn't fit right you know
why it doesn't fit right because there's
that one spot in the front of my head
where there's a cancerous tumor that you
didn't tell me
oh you want to talk about what's wrong
with my head already got it taken care
of so I look at Trent Williams right now
he's gonna sit there all week he's gonna
be there oh do it I'm gonna finish this
ring what would my question is yeah
earlier why'd he do it earlier why did
you do it in week one because because he
would have got paid all season long and
still had the same result so have you
ever seen a player we're like let's say
they're like Jalen Ramsay did down there
in Jacksonville right but I think also
Trent Williams is I don't know seven
eight years older he didn't have to go
in a training camp yeah I didn't have to
go in at all he's been able to spend all
of this time with his family and hang
out and relax he lost all of that money
that's but you know what Trent Williams
has been paid and because he's 31
he knows he's still gonna get a monster
contract he knows that you know look
it'sit's a little bit to go hey he lost
maybe like eight ten million dollars and
he's gonna make 40 or 50 but he still
lost eight or ten right but the part
that he was in was I don't want to go in
that bad because let me ask you if he
were to go in they would probably make
him do rehab all the time yes they'd
make him lift they make him do all of
that they'd probably make his life awful
no they would have made him lift they
probably had to do rehab however you're
gonna have to come in at 5:00 in the
morning that head injury night I can't
do any of those things my head but you
know what like if he's gonna get
qualified for a full season and he
sacrifices those first eight checks and
the training camp checks and he's okay
with of course but you know what he
knows he has a monster one coming and
that's that's how bad it must be but
he's not a free agent after this year
they can't keep them I shouldn't have
kept them this long I know to be honest
with you so what do you think this
organization that has it doesn't have
any foresight what are they gonna do if
what did I do now if they go through
what they just did with Alec with Kirk
Cousins where they franchise tagged him
two or three years in a row and got
nothing out of it if they end up going
through a very similar thing
Trent Williams what they said in the
beginning here we are not training him
we're not trading me he's gonna have to
play for the right now they're saying
they are and it's weird
well they should have did that I think
that was one of my favorite stories and
then pause to let deal come back one of
my favorite stories was that the team's
the NFL were annoyed that Washington for
months told them he's not on the trade
market and then on trade deadline day
said hey he interested and the rest of
the NFL team said no you're stuck with
them now that's my favorite story that's
what the Redskins get the rest of the
NFL said you [ __ ] that's what
they get that's exactly what they get
because the risk is they poop but they
messed up this entire process same way
that they did with Kirk Cousins welcome
back perfect time you you're perfect
time alright okay so now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go to the cup
okay
the cup is a number of random questions
that you have to read so this is your
life random questions and invoices this
is always David Ingeborg producer comes
up with it and it's better because I
would just come up with the same
questions every week and he's creative
alright we're gonna let you pick first
okay and I got to do it in a weird voice
the voice you're gonna do because I just
came back from London give me your best
British voice if the current version of
you could talk to your former self right
before his first NFL practice what
advice would you give mmm
is there more there no okay that's it
that's the top one
oh no I didn't read the bottom one - oh
if you are about to attend your first
NFL practice and some dude who looks
care ly like you but 20 years older just
randomly showed up and started giving
you advice would you listen so it's a
two-part question one if you go back in
time you go back in time when you're a
rookie what advice would you give by the
way great British accent thank you
that's the floods do that that's the
first quote what would you go back and
say to yourself before your very first
practice if you could go back in time
and see yourself at the practice field
the the first thing I would say is
you're gonna drop some balls don't be so
nervous cuz you're your first practice
you don't really know what to expect
you're kind of lost you kind of you're
amongst all these players that coaches
you go from a big fish in a small pond
to a small fish in a big pond so you're
nervous think you're a fisherman so
you're crazy Libyan you started so it
was I was before 450 back and so I was
kind of in line watching deuce go and
didn't Dorsey you just name it calm down
just calm down it's okay calm down it's
everything will work out just calm don't
you say anything about how your career
is gonna go I would say they're not
expecting very much from you anyway this
you're just working we're having some
next year would you look at yourself and
wink and be like it's hard because
number one we were a four and twelve
team that got gym fossil fired with four
games left in the season number one that
was the first time that I knew that this
was a business when you got to the NFL
because with four weeks left we find out
on Tuesday that he's no longer gonna be
the head coach and of course Wednesday
you start off with your special teams
meeting and then you have your team
meeting I love this story by the way so
Jim fossil walks in team meeting is
supposed to start about eight walks in
8:05 come storming in guys you know the
news after this season four games left
I'm no longer gonna be the head coach of
this football team but I want to let you
guys know this ship's going down but a
lot of you [ __ ] are coming
right with everybody on the team he
walked in and said ships going down and
a lot of you [ __ ] are coming
with me that's the way you do got four
games left to wear now the name on your
back of your Jersey represents something
and you better go out there and play
because not only this team but
thirty-one other teams are going to look
and see what the character of you are as
a football player and I was like whoa so
he walks out Wellington Mara walks in
and he's never in my entire time when he
was alive as a giant he's I've seen him
speak to the team twice hmm he walks in
gets to the podium gentlemen it's an
honor and a privilege to be a New York
giant
if you're not gonna go out there play
hard and represent this team the proper
way come up to my office I'll give you
your checks now and you can get the hell
out of here oh and he walked out of the
room I'm 21 I'm looking around like what
is going on right now holy this is the
NFL talk about walking in and realizing
the magnitude of the business of this
case so what was like the rest of the
day like well the rest of the season was
we lost those four games and in week 17
we're going out to play the Carolina
Panthers and you remember the old leg
over lower back stretch yes I look to my
left oh my god and look to my right I
have somebody suited up to me next to me
that I have never seen before in my life
and this is Sunday game day Sunday game
day the one o'clock game I'm looking
this and I'm looking over to guy Knight
we signed him on Saturday he was
starting on special teams in that game
if you go to and you add this and you
make this a 18-game schedule that's what
you're gonna be seeing week 18 so wait
so if you went back and saw rookie you
would you would you whisper in your ear
no say that or no no because you would
ruin it you have no ideas he would ruin
the first one maybe in the first maybe
that would go I know I got another one
coming no it sucked maybe go back and
wear elbow sleeves my entire career so I
don't have the bone chips and spurs in
my elbows that's a go under eleven
seasons but maybe that's it so the
follow-up question to that was now
imagine if you're a rookie and an older
Brian Westbrook walks up to you and an
older David deal walks up to you and
starts giving you advice would you
listen or would you be like what the
[ __ ] is happening if you don't listen to
you just foolish but if you also go to
like hold up why are you over there
telling me what to do you know what if
you walked up he you know what two Super
Bowl rings hey you're gonna listen to
you know what I know I know what I would
do if I was David David deal and talk to
my rookie self I would wear one of the
Super Bowl rings and I would look at him
and I go and I would just show it to him
because the reason is when you won that
second Superbowl you would appreciate
the fact that you didn't show on the
second Super Bowl yeah that would almost
be a surprise but the first one and it's
and the thing is - is your first one was
2007 yeah playing the 19 and OH Patriots
you would you you would everyone think
you're crazy because you'd be walking
around the locker room going to the guys
we're gonna win up to my 21 year olds oh
hey man listen you're gonna get all the
way to the NFC Championship go get a
bunch of those and guess what you're
gonna make it to the Super Bowl here's a
little tip for you there we go what
should Westbrook voice be David deal I
know do you pick me obviously before you
do it I'm gonna say Marlon Brando
Godfather someone offers you a job you
have to sit in the room Monday to Friday
for eight [ __ ] hours where can you do
where can you do nothing separate
sitting staring at clock what is the
minimum salary you'll accept so you got
a job money do Friday Friday eight hours
a day one hour lunch break you can do
nothing but stare at the clock what will
you accept for a salary yes you're in a
room and you're staring at a clock for
eight hours Monday through Friday and
you get any salary what is the minimum
salary you'd ask for and that's all
you're doing it's just staring at a
clock I mean people do that and they get
paid a lot all the time some people get
paid a lot of money and that's all they
do I don't know if I'd even give an
answer to this I don't know the minimum
salary but if I had to I guess something
like a billion dollars it's a billion
what yeah I just to do nothing all day
you don't have to get a billion dollars
to do nothing okay
haven't you seen office space of course
my cousin doesn't make anything and he
don't do [ __ ] but my
that to me is like going to jail for a
day like my job is going to jail five
days a week
and I don't know if there's a number
that you could pay me to do you know
what's crazy sorry my brother has a job
you can't interact with anybody you just
sit there similar the clock I doubt I
doubt you get vacation you know you get
very eight hours a day vacation my
brother had a job in he will always be
complaining like yo map go to work every
day and they don't give me anything to
do I'm like sounds like my job actually
what I do he hated it he literally told
me if they doubled my salary he still
wouldn't want to work here
hmm because they did nothing I'd lose my
mind if that's really yeah I've gotta be
busy man I guess twenty minutes I guess
whatever teddy bridgewater man I know a
bunch of people that make 50,000 bucks a
year that will make $50,000 we'll be
fine with that yeah give me $60,000 to
do that all day yeah to sit on the
internet and play game yeah but that's
you have the internet this is looking at
a clock
Westbrook what voice should I do for
mine yari did Scarface cuz you hated my
mom until you did scarf well yeah I kind
of discard yeah what about how about
your boy Patrick my Holmes okay we've
done that before you like that yeah it's
it always works
if mattad graded literally all of your
skills in what category would you score
of 90 plus surprise people
so if Madden's grading your skills David
deal what would you be a 90 plus set
that might surprise people um well I
don't think dur Billy would surprise
people non-football non-football so what
are you amazing at life that you'd be a
90 plus at that you think people will be
like wow David deals really at 90 plus
and that music what kind of music in the
sixties on I can listen to it tell you
who sang your x-men slash mad nobility
is song comes on and you can hit the
buzzer rock-and-roll jeopardy I'm
rolling Wow yeah came in here because
roses movie quotes be quotes yeah I
believe that though the question was I
don't believe it but being able to name
music yeah
priestly what about you you mentioned
music the first thing came to our mind
was karaoke you're a 90-plus Matt and
karaoke absolutely will to do karaoke is
90-plus Oh performance performance not
so good what would you say your number
one karaoke song is fascinating that
that's a good question
everybody has like one or two in the
back ice cube check yourself as mine
check yourself give me a little bit
without cursing making curse I'm not
gonna get into her right now I don't got
my Raiders hat on you gotta be gotta get
in the mood for karaoke what's yours
welcome bullets are bad for your health
I have to that's great I have to I have
one that I like to do solo and that
would be what's love by Fat Joe okay
ja rule a little song I can do the Fat
Joe rapping during Ashanti singing I let
the women in the audience sing and I
think I do a good job
rule impersonation ladies part Casey's
doing a great job coaching stranger
walking up to none can I be your Ashanti
so what's yours what would you if if we
all went out and you had to do karaoke
you know what letter you turn the book
to you gotta do something that everybody
loves like you know one of the songs
that everybody loves and this is one of
those songs that not appeal like people
love like TLC don't go chasing
waterfalls are they love songs like
scrubs overthought you know school stuff
everyone just knows these anything that
you can sing this for Michael Jackson
shelter no pigeons five the Jackson 5 if
you can sing any song from that which I
can't OC you would go Jackson five he's
gassy yes ABC what now come kill him
kill him he's got the
you got it you got to get you you got to
get moving a little bit but you want the
crowd participation because the last
thing you want is a karaoke singer that
can't sing yeah is this thing by
yourself well you've got to be an
entertainer up there that's a good
question not from the cup have you ever
done karaoke or anything on a stage with
a microphone that went really really
badly and you were like I'm actually a
little bit embarrassed has that ever
happened to you guys
yes okay and so most the time like you
guys giving speeches before most of time
you really need that crowd interaction
like a head nod like you guys understand
where you're coming like someone laughs
I made a joke and it's hilarious to me
and so I'm kind of chuckling and
everybody's like like recently this
actually wasn't very long it was a good
joke too and I remember what it was but
it was a good joke and nobody do you
have one mine is I did mine will be
karaoke to Phil Collins in the air of
the night it was right after hangover
came out and I really wanted to do the
drums on stage to do the first four
minutes of that song he's like speaking
sadly about like someone passing away
and the thing about karaoke is if the
lyrics are depressing everybody's
reading them oh yeah like there was that
song back in the day that was very
popular what would you do if your son
was at home crying all alone of a
bedroom floor cuz it's hungry okay it's
fun to sing yeah but when you see those
words in the TV the lyrics yeah slept
with a man for a little bit of money
because his daddy's gone and I'm sitting
there I was like here are the top 10
karaoke
karaoke songs Purple Reign Purple Reign
like a prayer by McDonagh purple purple
rain at the Superbowl halftime
I do tiny dancer before I would do a
rocket man alright so but see you gotta
come in hot when you carry you gotta
come you would do little Guns and Roses
maybe I've done I've done a little sweet
child of mine that's a good yeah comes
in with with right away with the guitar
yeah welcome to the jungle you have to
stand up to there during many no no no
no no no no no no no no no right that
was welcome to the job yeah first part
about karaoke is there you're reading
the words you like hold on these have
these are not the words I've been
singing I remember the first time I
heard a song revved up like a deuce yeah
and I thought he was saying revved up
like a douche blinded by the light yeah
yeah yeah what's the song that goes oh
oh it's magic next time you hear that
you're gonna hear oh it's my dick you
never told us what your your your
characteristics that's ninety nine and
no one with oh um my characteristic that
I'm really good at that people wouldn't
realize [ __ ] listening no I'm just man I
really don't know my x-men ability I
think is getting uber drivers not to
talk to me really yeah and I'm amazing
at Stone him out you know you don't like
talking to drive no no I sit down and as
soon as I walk in the car I go hey man I
apologize if I fall asleep and then the
guy goes dude relax take your time and
I'm like oh really I look at my phone oh
yeah everything you're doing you all the
way I don't like I think I'm really
efficient at getting through congested
places like I bet you love being in a
club and just like kind of busting
through people I'm so good at finding
lanes in bars clubs airports train
stations Times Square you follow me you
not even gonna get touched you know
what's so funny is for one year my new
year's resolution was I'm not gonna move
out of the way of people I'm the biggest
guy walking and people run into me and
they look at me like I'm the SS I'm like
why do I gotta move expect you so their
new year's resolution I come out I'm
blasting people laughter right Tina my
fiance he's like you're gonna you're
gonna get arrested I don't agree with
you because if people think oh well
you're huge you can get right through
you can take his people are gonna call
you the jerk they're gonna get in your
way and they're gonna be the ones
disrupted I think that I'm just enough
smaller than you well I mean I'm a lot
smaller than you but I think that like I
could see people looking at you and
being like in a weird way you're taking
up space
yeah well I'm awkward big but I'm also
really good like I don't just do all
physical brute strength which clearly is
what I'm I'll tap someone on their left
shoulder and walk by the right like I
use the scroll the tricks turn a sharp
corner to get into the men's bathroom
yeah tre Nicole you're up now and let's
do because you did it last week and I
went here now I wanna hear your Arnold
Schwarzenegger
how often do you find yourself toggling
at your t-shirt away from your
midsection that's it that was such a
good Austin so the question was how
often do you tug at your t-shirt so I
doubt you guys have seen the show on
Netflix it's called I think you should
leave Tim Robinson it's hilarious guy
and one of the segments is about this
thing called t-shirt tuggers where he
puts like a little knob because a lot of
guys do this I do it all the time
because this hat and the Wall Street
Journal just put out an article about
guys we notice that you tug at your
shirts maybe you've had that t-shirt for
how often how often do you pull out the
middle of your t-shirt or your shirt in
general I you know what I don't pull at
the front
I'm usually pulling at the back in the
side pull it down in the back because
usually with my you know dress shirts or
whatever feel like they're bunched up
you got a suture because I have serious
love handles I'm always I'm always
pulling and stretching in the back get
down with your collar and get everything
out here more than I am the front you're
you're a t-shirt tug I do it here
because I don't know how warm it is in
here it has to be one hundred and five
hundred six degrees in the air to read
it so I'm always like I need oh I do it
did this offer here you do I would say
estimated 72 times a day really oh yeah
one cuz I'm always like oh if my shirts
flowing off they won't notice that I
need to go to the gym are you sweating
as well or you just and then practically
gets stuck yeah give it a quick tug yeah
I'm not trying to look like I'm inside
of an accordion or some [ __ ] you know
you mention your New Year's Eve your New
Year's resolution just made me think
about I'm gonna have one I have a pet
peeve about people not saying thank you
and I hold the door I hate I love that
new year's resolutions because it's not
things you want to improve it's things
that no I'm gonna say excuse me you're
welcome I'm gonna start saying things
like I think it's gonna be rude like
they're being rude thing if you hit him
with a strong you're welcome because the
excuse me is like I'd like to have a
conversation yeah but the you're welcome
they're either gonna turn around and say
thank you or they're gonna say I'm sorry
if you say excuse me then you're the
dick there are so many people that walk
through the door they're talking and
we're doing whatever with their phone
and they just keep on walking I'm yeah
I'm not here to hold you I'm trying to
get it back to to hold wherever you were
at I want to go there I think you should
go chick-fil-a on them and say my
pleasure my pleasure my lady
yeah one thing I learned in London that
I really liked is there's kind of levels
to their thank-yous so like if I bought
you something you might say thank you if
I hold the door they go cheers mate
cheers man I like that they used
years as like a half way thank you I
asked them about this they confirmed it
halfway halfway yeah your turn Westbrook
and you're gonna do a cartoon bully
what is the cartoon bully just think
about like how a bully and a high school
cartoon would have no collection Simpson
you know what Nelson is is Nelson the
most famous cartoon bully well Roger
Klotz that was from Doug and and figure
you know you never saw the couch with
Diff'rent Strokes you never knew who
you've never different strokes so I'm
looking at top ten cartoon bullies Eric
Cartman isn't okay Nelson from The
Simpsons is too then it's fairly
oddparents Angelica pickles from Rugrats
Lucy kinda was a yeah Peter Griffin
wasn't a bully no all right no I think
Nelson might be and then it was a go at
Bluto blue hop yeah it's great just
actually there was like that creepy
section of bullies where it was like it
was always involved in like steel like
physically taking a woman and being like
she's mine and now it's like that's
problematic a Internet me as soon as you
think this is a novel idea no one's ever
thought about this you go on the
internet there's 20 of them so it's
great top 20 but yeah you could do it
yeah I'm fully all right but I don't
have no clue what it cause every time I
start I'm like this doesn't sound like a
cartoon you're being an [ __ ] it
sounds like a bully I'm gonna be okay
all right man how many motivated angry
fourth graders could Quintin Nelson beat
up at the same time dude you know dude
was kind of thing ding Murr says that I
have a few catchphrases one of them as I
go Daniel you do do dance like that and
then any Brad forget the other one oh my
god I gotta go
that's awesome that's all so apparently
I'm bear will like be around me but
that's awesome yeah how many how many
fourth graders trying to fight Quintin
Nelson could quit Nelson take it
that time let's switch work up could he
take five fourth-graders of these yeah
yes one hand clear what he might do he
just run through him yes verse five he
looks through looks at him where he
gives a growl they're out of there and
let's say that these are not tactical
fourth-graders they don't understand
flanking they don't understand using
space they adore opens and fourth
graders run out wit Nelson is
front-facing and hey Liam if ten fourth
graders ran out could quit Nelson take
yeah I think so too about it what he
would do step up okay let's what would
he do what he would go that they would
be there kind of so it's ten of them so
they're kind of like in a line three by
three so they're not gonna be all be one
by one and he just goes hit bust the
first one that's gonna scare off two or
three right there nice the other two he
just squishes them and push I see more
backhands I see just running through
them I'll see you see him attack yes
okay does a bullying guy I'm a big boy
did you watch Game of Thrones at all
yeah okay so you know how like the White
Walkers
they don't have fear they just come yeah
that's how I'm imagine these fourth
graders these are not fourth graders
because a sensible fourth grader would
walk in sea quit Nelson and go mommy but
these are talking about like the step
brothers fourth graders that are ready
to roll
could he handle 25 that's a lot no no no
you're gonna hit son to be wrapped up on
your legs some of these fourth graders
are getting big some of these guys are
big kids now they're 5 feet 10 inches
that was a heavy fourth grade or maybe I
could have just laid on them try to get
the other kids out there well I think
you know how many quitting else can
handle just a bit more than Teddy
Bridgewater's gonna get paid so 25 think
he if there was like a combine event
where this was it I think he did beat
them all out I think he'd be in like the
48 like whatever like Stephen Paia did
in the bench press the comma
that's six more like a guy behind and
like smacking the sides be like give me
the two kids who flunked I would think
he could take more kids with good grades
than kids with bad grades because I
think kids with bad grades would fight
more you there are the bullies there the
Nelson he wants the nerdy kids yeah old
nerdy kids he's up at around 74 he could
beat them yeah analytics to take down
and well you know we're gonna go this
angle oh yeah
in terms of fourth-graders per minute
for that what was Carter how did Cartman
sound no clue I can't I can't I'm gonna
do Cartman for this one which player
would be the next tony romo in the
broadcast booth Greg Iles
you both played you know the grind you
know what it takes you also know how we
favor quarterbacks in Super Bowl winners
kind of what we do I watch Greg Olson I
think he's already pretty [ __ ]
fantastic
yeah like I need Saul ready started he's
already gotten into a game so that's an
easy one to pick is there anybody else
of the of the true stars of the game
again a lot of true stars don't actually
go into the broadcast booth because
they've made so much money but I think
you know it would be an a crazy scene if
a Antonio Brown gets the job in the
broadcast booth I mean [ __ ] Fox already
hired Gronk and I'm like rocky and
really putting sentences together I
don't know you can't hire yeah well a
lot of people didn't like Randy Moss for
a long time and obviously he went to New
England and the change didn't like Ray
Lewis for a very long time yeah and he's
been he was on the ESPN for a long time
when Randy Moss what if Randy Moss did
not go to New England he would have the
same stigma that Terrell Owens had yeah
yeah yeah you know all the outrage in
Oakland everything that happened in
Minnesota if he didn't go and have the
type of career when he went to New
England had those touchdown records
and went with the Patriots way he would
not be there deshaun Watson good good
choice yeah but yeah stand ups Wilson
iving Larry Fitzgerald Russell wolf
Russell Wilson's a good one that's a
good one yeah it's interesting but
articulate what else those guys make 150
like 150 million I'm like they're not
gonna work on television look at Peyton
Peyton's is going around doing fun
commercials actually yeah
for years he's been putting off TV yeah
because he doesn't really doesn't have
to know I don't feel it rivers I don't
know a little bit too spicy for TV it's
funny cuz people say he's got to take
care of his kids but he might be going I
don't need to take care of these kids
you know what you know who would be good
and I think would I would really like to
see Richard Sherman yes because yeah
because perspective because it'd be the
defensive side of the ball guys you get
a lot of different players and also the
thing with Richard Sherman is he'd be
really good at kind of talking about the
media while also being in the media tree
and all these wide receivers that heave
clashed with I would imagine that they
would still be playing and then also
with this second wave with this Niners
right now he's not just the legion of
boom guy this Niners team is gonna make
a run yeah so he could be on this team
that that could be Super Bowl contenders
for the next 2-3 years and you know how
when you have like those two careers now
you can comment on like two eras of the
NFL yeah what are you laughing about
in my mind Quintin Williams just popped
up in my head like he needs to be in the
booth but you listened offensive lineman
just they have a different way of
looking at the game cerebral smart they
see it both sides
they make great analysts women because
we never watch the football when we
watch it again exactly one position that
Iran my entire career I never knew where
the ball it's also I know where it was
supposed to be yes what the defense in
the way that they moved in the way that
they float told me where the football
was also the only position that we have
to trust people on their evaluations to
know
who's being good who's been good or not
if you don't know what you're looking us
right yeah I can look at yards per catch
for wide receivers and certain
statistics that are mattering and PFF
can grade that and understand it
completely but with offensive linemen
you know there may you may technically
have led up a sack but it wasn't your
fault yeah and the only people really
understand people don't understand man
versus zone hands yeah I literally I sit
there on Sundays and when I go through
and I watch games or go back and watch
the review of games you know many have
no idea how many times offensive line
play is told 60 to 70% wrong because
they just don't understand they don't
understand the game they don't
understand protections I'll just tell
you this a lot of times when you're
looking at a protection or if you're
looking at a system where the running
back is offset to the right now all of a
sudden they're sliding protections this
way and the Blitz is coming this way and
the running back releases he's not there
just to go out on the route you know
you're sliding the protection the other
way because you don't have numbers on
that side oh these damn old linemen and
once it's not our responsibility this
happens time and time again hey listen
don't come in here blaming all the
running backs the tight end of the wide
receivers didn't go hot on it I want to
make sure it's good it's good
I want you to do this is the last one oh
it's it's one more I the last one right
and I want you to do
Eli Manning you're good for an Eli yeah
well thirty-two Mitchell chobits keys
were the starting quarterbacks of every
team I don't know who would be the top
five Superbowl favorites I like that you
did like the hair put hair push back so
the question is if the quarterback of
every team in the NFL was Mitchell true
Biscay who would be the top five teams
that you think could make around the
Super Bowl
Patriots obviously gotta have a great
defense exactly where I put San
Francisco there yes because Jimmy
Garoppolo hasn't been that great and
they've still been great to the running
game
there too yep okay who else you guys
putting in it could you imagine how
disappointing the NFL will be to watch
can't you put Seattle there no and
that's like Rio must feel like you could
put Buffalo there because of the way
their defense is playing in Josh I think
is nothing we need to do is think also I
mean that's why it's stuff like here's
the deal like Green Bay and Seattle
relies so heavily on their quarterbacks
that's why I mean that's why I wouldn't
even mention those like I think Green
Bay has a very good team but they're
still ruling team blue team is winning
this not relying on their Court of us
San Francisco represent great dude Tom
Brady has not been that great yes true I
mean obviously is that what Alice Dennis
maybe Dallas maybe you on that edge
centric to where I could see that makes
sense yeah Indianapolis I think look man
that's what he's been playing Baltimore
not happening yeah
Kansas City not happening he can't run
that Houston no Buffalo is an
interesting one
Janice Odell is an interesting one
Minnesota really teams they can run it
40 times the game has been pretty good
last come yeah but what we're saying is
it's just overall good defense and all
you do is hand off to Dalvin and
occasionally throw a deep man Mitchell's
kind of tough huh mr. Chicago yeah what
are your friends at home right now
saying about truth I mean group chat
what do you and I have had this
discussion before because going into
this season with all this hype and all
the MVP stuff what was the first thing I
said to you if there's anybody that
Mitchell true Biscay should be happy
about its Cody parky mm-hmm because
nobody remembered the second half of
that Philadelphia game where he threw a
horrible interception and was completely
inaccurate in the second half I will
stand in for mr. Biscay
he did lead a really good Drive with to
get down there for the field goal and he
was good at the very end of the game
okay but he did he thinks yeah just
stinks it's just hard to watch your
Biscay is hard to Alan Robinson on that
some of his throws like his
decision-making hasn't been good
his throw ease obviously he likes to
throw the ball to the other team he
doesn't score it I mean it's weird to
watch that team you're like you mean to
tell me that this office that looks so
creative last year yeah I can't score
now look and no one that you can take
risks with the type of defense you have
on the other side of the ball I watched
at 4:00 a.m. in the morning at a casino
in London Matt Moore who was retired and
coaching and a high school scout is off
season and scouting go in there and look
calm poised and professional in the
pocket make a ton of throws and never
look shaken
I watched try Biscay now and every time
I watch him he's looking at the ground
he's looking at the rush
he's rolling backwards when it's not
even necessary he's targeting one guy I
see not only no place that I go like
even Jacobi Brissette didn't play a
great game but he still made a few plays
that were like wow yeah I don't see wow
plays and I also see no growth no no
grow Matt Nagy should be a quarterback
to be able to develop a quarter yeah you
think if if Ryan pace the GM of the
Bears and them are smart they will take
the hit and they will move on from turbo
ski and they will not give him any
contract well they have and they will
have to start over but they they have to
do gave up a bunch of pics to get Khalil
Mack that means you gotta win now you
got a great defense you gotta win now I
get this guy that's gonna win that's why
they have to do exactly what you said
they it's time to move on degrees just
so hard because a GM never wants to
admit our first ever wonder horse or Tom
Brady and josh mcdaniels as they move
over to Chicago just that is the key
okay I could talk to you guys that was a
lot of fun did you have fun absolutely
you know I love this stuff that was a
blast
all right so cue the music he his tag
line has become the Rocket Man so I'm
gonna go around and say Brian Westbrook
he's gonna do his thing understand me
I'll save you for the last I'll say
David deal and whatever you want your
tagline to be up OK for Brian West rush
the Rocket Man on the lef koe man
for David deal that's a done deal Oh
some of you guys hit up David here what
is your social again is at my Instagram
is done deal 66 and at Dave deal 66 Oh
Phillip is mentions let them know how
[ __ ] awesome he is and where can we
watch your [ __ ] right now I Wednesdays I
have serious Sundays I've got WFAN
Sunday football free postgame shows for
the Giants I'm rolling baby he is
[ __ ] roll and hit him up on social
hit up Westbrook Westbrook 36 calm 36
where he last free Westbrook doctor
Westbrook doctor right and if you don't
follow me on social go [ __ ] yourself